if you like basketball or Justin Bieber
supermodels odds are you've seen this
thing that I run it's called actually I
don't know what it's called
it's kind of like a Segway but with no
handlebars or it's a sideways skateboard
or a scooter thing some people call it a
hoverboard which I like the one I bought
is called two wheels smart
self-balancing scooters drifting board
electric cost me five hundred and ninety
five dollars you can buy it for a lot
more though from companies like io hawk
phunkee duck it's their products that
people like Justin Bieber Kendall Jenner
and JR Smith riding around but those are
basically the exact same thing as this
here's how it works it has two wheels
each one independently controlled you
ride it by applying pressure to two foot
pads one on either side and it uses a
gyroscope to keep it balanced it takes a
few minutes to get used to but once you
stop trying to do too much you get the
hang of it pretty quickly it's really
really fun to ride they'll go about six
miles an hour up to about twelve miles
before the battery dies though these
cheap knockoffs will actually go even
faster
all these boards come from basically the
same place which is surprise China it
started with one company who invented it
and then was immediately copied by the
same factories that make knockoff
iPhones knockoff Harry Potter's and
knockoff Starbucks that's our China does
best and this hoverboard has spread like
wildfire both there and in the US with
more and more companies trading it's
really just a toy and an expensive one
at that
right now the brand-name ones which
don't forget are all basically just the
same as this one I have here cost as
much as eighteen hundred dollars but the
beauty of the way these things work is
that they're going to get cheaper and
better fast the companies that sell it
are already designing better safer
boards and the price is coming down
really fast in a few months these things
are going to be everywhere so put it on
your Christmas list and maybe wear a
helmet first time you try it oh it was a
pretty solid dismount there too